and behind you aimed right at those
Hoysala ruins
it's an old fortress just beyond those
waterfalls trident mark on the map for
you let's see what's behind the boulder
another old fortress sitting smack dab
in the middle of the lake bed I'll jot a
bow on the map in that spot last but not
least the axe door and another old
fortress tucked into the mountainside
I'll just mark that on the map with an
axe hey everyone I'm Lucy and I'm Oscar
and this is some beautiful footage of
Uncharted The Lost Legacy so sadly we
have to talk over it cuz them's the
rules but we can't enjoy this
playthrough so Oscar you have actually
played the game how long do you play it
for and it was this a section in it etc
I played it for about 45 minutes
yesterday and this was okay so basically
it's complicated
there's a big open yeah basically that
is my facebook status right now so you
get this of mini open-world hub area
with three fortresses that you can
tackle in any order that you want I
picked one of them that was what I had
time for this is not the footage that we
have so yeah this is gonna be fun
so yeah I tackled one of the fortresses
in this open world but the main
impression that came away with after
playing Uncharted The Lost Legacy was
that we remember uncharted 4 is
basically that again
I mean it was fun but it was of after
how different uncharted 4 was to
uncharted 3 for example this don't
expect any more groundbreaking strides
with the lost legacy it feels very very
similar to enjoyed for in lots of ways
that the combat is the same the stealth
is the same even though so that this
section is set in the Western Ghats of
India
and this is very similar to a lot of
what we saw on a chart for in terms of
the landscape exactly yeah and and the
Madagascar level is what they kept
referring to as well and even though
we're on the other side of the world it
still looks very similar so yeah is is
more of the same I mean it's it's
understandable because this did actually
start out as DLC front charge for that
they said it then just grew too big for
a DLC pack and that they wanted to tell
a bigger story and that was why it
became its own standalone game but yeah
it feels very very similar would you say
it feels more like the last of us left
behind
maybe yeah that was so that was like an
add-on that basically explored secondary
characters which is very much what it
looks like the last Lexie's doing plays
Chloe you've got Nadine back in the mix
exactly yes so you play as Chloe rather
than the Dean and yeah you're right it
feels it feels very similar to Left
Behind I think it's gonna be longer than
that they didn't I did I actually asked
them how long is it gonna be for you is
$40 and I think 30 pounds in the UK so
it's not a full price release and I did
ask them like how long is it gonna be is
it a full game and they were like they
were very adamant that it's a full
Uncharted game but they wouldn't they
wouldn't say how long it is they said it
would be smaller than than uncharted 4
but longer than previous uncharted and
yeah so I think it's longer than left
behind I think left behind was only
something like three hours or something
else it was it was real short so but
you're right it's similar in that it
does explore secondary characters I get
the feeling it's gonna be a story that
doesn't really need to be told because
if it needed to be told then it would be
in the main game right
I did I did feel very sad that Chloe
wasn't in enjoyed for yeah she's she's a
really cool character she is a great
character but what if I'm really
interesting was that they said that the
reason that they picked Chloe for this
DLC or now standalone expansion or
whatever you want to call it the reason
they picked her was that they kept
coming back to her when they were
brainstorming who this expansion should
be about because she's be
this thief for all of her life always
been self preservationist and never
wanting to care about anyone else really
but they wanted to see whether she could
become the Nathan Drake of this world
was what they said and I thought it was
really interesting it's like well this
world has already got on Nathan Drake
his name is Nathan Drake right
I mean spoilers for the end of anti for
him I feel like I'm Nathan is moving
away from that life like he has his
family and stuff no he has his daughter
I guess East Point he's busy playing
Crash Bandicoot Kula so it might be that
I don't know if like spin off wise you
would maybe assume that Nathan's
daughter would maybe be a good fit but I
think also Chloe's a great bit because
she she's already so well established
its curtains yeah definitely and and in
the future if they were to do more I
would like to see more of Sam as well
Sam and Sully seemed like a really that
could be a really cool dynamic but you
know bringing her back to Lost Legacy
Chloe in the d-n-r of really cool couple
of characters and I'm really looking
forward to seeing where they go with it
but yeah I don't know I get the feeling
that given how similar it is to
uncharted 4 and given that like I said
it if it needed to be told it would be
in the main game right I just get the
feeling it's gonna feel a little bit
superfluous even if you know at the end
of day it's an uncharted game uncharted
has never been a bad game
mechanically uncharted 4 is probably the
best of the bunch see I think the
chickens are where I actually like most
people like my one big gripe with lunch
I don't think they've ever got the
shooting white right Uncharted 4 was a
definite like leaps and bounds in the
right direction but I feel like still
that's something it needs to be but I
mean I basically stealth I'm tired for
because I thought I preferred that way
of playing and we saw there that Chloe's
doing issues like taken away through
those guys yeah that's another thing
that they're very they were being very
clear that they wanted this game to be a
little more it was pushing player choice
a little bit harder than previous
Uncharted have so they were sort of
going for the the three tiered approach
of you can go in all guns blazing or you
can go in and try and stealth kill
everyone or you can try and slip past
everyone so that segment you just saw I
actually did so that's
like a random outpost that you can come
across in this mini hub world and when I
came across and they like I was an idiot
and just ran straight into their base
and so they were already shooting at me
so I didn't have the option to go
stealth so there was interesting to see
it from a perspective where though he
was trying to stealth it
I actually stealth the fortress that I
did yeah
even though it looked like it probably
would have been easier because you know
uncharted is more of an action-oriented
game than a than a stealth oriented game
I would say it probably would have been
easier if I'd have just gone in and shot
everyone up but like I did yeah I took
too long stealth everyone see yeah it's
pushing that player choice but it one
thing to bear in mind is that although
this section has that player choice and
has the choice not only in how to
approach each fortress but in what order
to approach the fortresses that I don't
think is going to be the case for the
whole game like I did ask them is this
representative of the game as a whole
like because there was that Madagascar
section and in uncharted 4 right where
it's similarly open but then the rest of
that game was quite linear yeah and I
asked him if that was going to be the
same with this and they were like yeah
you know it's not gonna be it's not
gonna be this open for the entire thing
so you know there are going to be
sections where I imagine where you have
to self it they're probably gonna be
sections where you have to go in all
guns blazing so player choice is not
gonna be there for the whole thing this
isn't suddenly turning into Far Cry but
yeah for this section
it was quite open which was I guess a
refreshing change for a series that is
mostly quite linear what did you think
of the we just saw a little bit of like
a character interaction between the two
and that was my favorite part of
uncharted 4 is that the way that
characters you know you just sort of
leave them like you can hop out you can
be like where are you going
yeah there is yeah that this a similar
thing happened in the section that I did
as well and there are these new
collectables called Hoysala tokens I
think I'm pronouncing that right please
don't attack me in the comments if I'm
pronouncing it wrong so these are
basically
collectibles that when you when you pick
them up they give you a little bit more
background about the area that you're in
and they can open up extra dialogue
trees and stuff like that with the other
character so I think there's going to be
more of the same that we saw in
uncharted 4 I get the feeling that who
style tokens aren't gonna be this
groundbreaking addition to the Uncharted
franchise but you know it's a nice
addition that that you know you can get
a little bit more juice of this lovely
big orange we have in front of us that
was a weird emoji so these so these
towers right they kind of a reminiscent
to me as like the tombs from tomb raider
yeah I guess so I mean I I've only
played one tomb raider game in the whole
franchise so yeah the 2013 reboot okay I
didn't play rise of the planet of the
war for the tomb raider exposed the
original tomb raider
no it sold in it and I'm only like I'm
gonna need ten tombs in 2013 tomb raider
I can't remember that game cuz it was
like it was like basically uncharted but
not as good but yeah I mean you've got
these I mean I don't think there's gonna
be towers throughout the whole of the
game I think it is just this one section
where you have like the three towers
that you have to tackle in any order and
like I said I think is going to be more
linear and more classic uncharted for
the rest of it but yeah I don't know do
you do you prefer uncharted or tomb
raider no you tell us the mass here no
offense
I prefer uncharted storytelling
characters basic like the whole movie
snake but I like the bow
to major a lot you like the bow know me
that that's good bow goodbye
in terms of bodies yes so we've got the
villain in this is a sob he's this lady
can I just say I can see Oscars notes
from here it's just written villain is a
sob creepy he is creepy
he is creepy I mean we didn't get to
learn too much more about him he's in
the trailer as well he's this I'm
getting film he is creepy he's getting
some like I'm getting some weird like
creepy scary ominous looking for Soros
yeah a little bit like in that is
actually what I was thinking in my head
he is very similar to us from Far Cry 3
like some weird but not South African
like he's some I'm getting like a creepy
I'm gonna say again European doctor vibe
yeah yeah that will then go horribly
wrong
yeah he's gonna sabotage my plastic
surgery so that he can get his hands on
the treasure purse yeah he looks like
he's gonna be a really cool character I
mean certainly like you said the
characters on top I'd have always been
great and that carried on with uncharted
4 and I think it's gonna carry on again
with this that villain I think I think
it's gonna be a better villain than what
was the dude with the hair in uncharted
4 I forgot his name
[Music]
but yeah the fact that we can't remember
the guy with the hair he's in in my mind
at least he's just the guy with the hair
I feel like I feel like anti games they
always put a lot of effort into their
protagonist and maybe their antagonists
don't get as much yeah I'm just sort of
evil for the sake of being able for
maybe like Harry or someone here yeah
Harry was a really like yeah I saw of
you don't really get as invested in the
villains yeah but I think that could
change with the self he is shaping up to
be a really really cool villain even I
mean he wasn't given much like backstory
other than
some reason he has a personal connection
to the golden tusk which is sort of like
that's the thing you're chasing after in
this game okay yes so Chloe has a
personal connection to it also feels
that he has a personal connection to it
so that's sort of the thing that you're
both chasing after other than that he
wasn't give a huge amount of backstory
but yeah he's gonna be really cool I
think all right guys well thank you so
much for watching uncharted the Lost
legacy is out at the end of August but
more make sure you keep your eyes peeled
to youtube.com slash GameSpot or guess
welcome